you mentioned Magnus and kuryakin
uh
and I just wonder if you have ideas
thoughts about uh the fact that he was
originally a qualifier for the
candidates tournament was disqualified
um by feed a for breaching his code of
ethics about the related to his support
for uh the Russian invasion of Ukraine
uh does that ever
seep into the the games that you play
over the board the the geopolitics the
actual military conflict of it all do
you feel the pressure of that because
there's battles between nations nepos uh
you know Russian there's this America
there's I mean every nation is in some
profound way represented on the
chessboard right I've I've never really
felt that I think actually for me it's
very eye-opening to realize how
difficult it is for a lot of the Russian
chess players right now to play because
of the situation even nepo for that
matter I remember when we were in St
Louis he he essentially has to bring
cash because obviously Russia's cut off
from Swift no no credit cards work so if
these Russians don't have cash they
can't play and I know a lot of them have
fled the country just to try and keep
their chess career going so it's it's a
very very very tough situation for them
obviously for the ukrainians who are
suffering
um it's it's really really bad do you
know if nepo this has he talked haven't
seen as he talked about
the politics the the geopolitics of it
all I I don't think he really has I I
mean I I feel like most players try to
avoid talking about I think it's very
difficult I remember when I was in St
Louis there's another Russian player
Peter savidler and I I basically asked
him he's like don't get me started
because I I can't I just can't talk
about it um so I think most of them are
probably on the other side of the
spectrum I don't think they're probably
supportive of what is going on right now
so it's it's very it's a very very
difficult situation but I don't really
feel like that manifests itself in
actual like tensions when I play against
like the Russian players I mean maybe
when I was younger playing certain
events the the one country I felt like
maybe it actually I felt some tension I
really want to go out of my way to
winning us was against the Chinese
perhaps that is maybe the one time I
felt something along those lines
um but generally I feel like we treat
the players as individuals it's not
about the country they represent